[Music]
he has called the Germans and the Dutch
Nazis his officials have been banned
from a number of European countries and
he threatens to break a hard bargain
migration deal weeks ahead of a
referendum meant to bolster his powers
Turkey's president air Dewan is not
making any new friends in Europe with
tensions running high the European
Parliament has asked to once again to
cut short negotiations with Turkey which
is still a candidate for membership in
the EU it's good that we condemn
everything what is happening in Turkey
but at a certain moment mr. president of
the Commission amidst the President of
the Council let's be honest let's freeze
the accession negotiations now no mr.
Merlo balloon of robbery yet one of this
is DC pathani of a Ukrainian villa di
personal data and access to TS Yamini
tangle steered occupy republic arrow
with increasing alarm the EU has watched
as air Dewan used to last year's
attempted coup d'etat as an excuse to
punish opponents and consolidate his
presidential power though Turkey is
Europe's fifth largest trade partner and
the EU is turkey's primary export market
parliament has postponed discussing the
enhancement of the customs union deal
with turkey Emme peas want to wait until
after the referendum before deciding how
to move forward
[Music]